so in May of this year 2017 I decided
after several emails from people
requesting content people who had seen
the conversations I'd had with Jordan
Peterson I decided to start making
content for my YouTube channel I made a
few symbolic interpretations of movies
but quickly move towards broader ideas
of symbolism religious worldview the
Bible and and I see this expanding more
and more as time goes along by the way
and Jordan Peterson has been paramount
in bringing most of you here to my
channel by sharing this content on
Twitter so Jordan if you're watching
this you have my unending gratitude and
as I put out more videos I have been
having mountains of fun and I've also
been really touched and excited to read
people's thoughtful comments in the and
questions in the videos but also getting
so many amazing emails and messages on
other platforms
you know recounting people's journeys
and and their new more profound
discovery of Christianity or just even
the possibility of God or religious
language in general and mostly this
awakening to how symbolic patterns fill
our experience of the world and and
every time I read a message of how
someone's life has been changed I mean
every time I read one of those messages
the more these videos take up space in
my mind and in my schedule but out but
to be honest I mean I'm already a
struggling artist trying to support
three kids with icon carving and I know
that I haven't nearly been able to do as
much as I wish I could do with these
videos so here's the deal I'm putting up
a patreon page for these videos I mean I
already love what I do
I mean I pinch myself every day that I'm
allowed to carve icons for a living I
mean I can't imagine I would ever let
that go completely but I'm also really
excited at the possibility of exploring
more simple
like ideas with you guys more
interpretations of Bible stories stories
in general exploring how symbolism
shapes our lives on on every level so
you know we could we could dive deeper
in how symbolic patterns shape social
and political events we could look at
ancient and modern history and art and
architecture and all the strange and
surprising traditions in our Western
Canon you can look at the great cycles
of epochs from Troy to Alexander the
Great to King Arthur I mean we could
look at mythology fairy tales folk
stories movies and all kinds of popular
phenomena I mean really the sky's the
limit
symbolism is everywhere and my eyes are
never tired of looking and I I mean
obviously I have this this image that we
could become a generation of people who
once again see these forgotten patterns
in the world and so making us able to
act as mediators you know as a bulwark
against the polarizing pendulum swing of
the contemporary chaos there's nothing
that I would love more than that and
especially especially I think we could
be a bridge by continuing to explore how
the modern scientific worldview and the
ancient symbolic worldview can come
together and work as a team I mean can
you imagine the results if we could
break through that barrier so basically
this is what I'm gonna do I'm gonna let
all of you decide how big a place this
will take in my life so so if you felt
that these videos have been valuable to
you maybe even valuable in waking up a
sleeping Generation please consider your
support in return I promise better
quality videos more videos but also at
some point a blog and podcast versions
of the videos reading lists and as much
more as we can get to like I said I am
willing to follow all of you in this and
see where
it's going to lead so check out my new
patreon page linked in the description
and get involved here in the comments I
mean I'm offering rewards right now
which are mostly private conversations
with me and maybe some say in what the
content of these videos will be but you
know I'm open to all kinds of ideas of
what you would like to see doing you
know AMAs you're doing certain types of
question and answer on video or through
or or through text I can also involve my
art maybe carve something all of you
would vote for I don't know I mean I'm
open to possibilities and all I know is
I want to team up with all of you so
that we can play our little part and
changing the world with all this new
center ship going on I will not use
YouTube's monetization schemes and also
I think it's also important for me not
to create reserve content which would be
just for patrons I I think that what
we're trying to do what I'm trying to do
is is just too important to to reserve
it to a single few and what as many
people as possible to see these so I'm
leaving it up to you I'm leaving next
week the first week of September for 3
weeks to give carving workshops in the
United States so when I get back
hopefully we can take this to the next
level so see you soon
you